for decades cities have invested in
building up their public transit systems
and reducing the number of cars on the
road hundreds of millions of people
flock to transit hubs around the world
every day as they travel into work in
the mornings and go home at night or at
least they used to
the corona virus pandemic has turned the
daily commute into a public health risk
from swiping a subway ticket to touching
a payment screen or squeezing onto a
crowded train the way many of us used to
travel now means risking exposure to a
deadly virus that's the perfect scenario
for the virus to be transmitted because
you've got so many people packed in so
closely the risk of infection is
actually quite quite considerable to get
people to commute again many
transportation networks are trying to
make that journey safer in some cities
this has set off a race to find
different ways for people to move so we
wanted to know how is the pandemic
changing the way we commute a good place
to start is with trains before cities
can start building out their grand
visions for the future they have to deal
with the immediate issue of social
distancing and sanitization mandatory
masks social distancing signs and one
way walking systems have all become new
normals in cities like London and Paris
but the reality of reopening cities
means that some transit systems can get
overwhelmed pretty easily and
overcrowding makes social distancing
particularly difficult so many are
focusing more on deep cleaning the MTA
is testing a UV light system to try and
kill kovat 19 in rich countries you can
even talk about nanotechnology to
recover or cover the inside of buses or
public transit with surfaces that repel
or kill the virus in Hong Kong these
robots are rolling through trains spring
disinfectants some Beijing subway
stations are using a temperature
screening system to check for potential
fevers while also using mobile
reservations to try
manage the flow of people and cleaners
are using electrostatic spray or packs
to clean trains in many places but
measures like these can be expensive
professor Julio Davila researches cities
and transportation systems in Latin
America the Middle East Africa and Asia
unless it gets to this extent that is
affordable by cities in the global south
I don't see that happening any time soon
one way to make ride safer is by not
letting trains get too full and that
means sacrificing some ticket sales
which in turn means less money to
operate those same trains one thing
that's clear is that public transit
systems around the world are in very
difficult financial situation unlike
rail systems roads are a little easier
to modify for public transit all of the
advantages we've got with how you manage
the road network is you can implement
measures pretty quickly but you're
redesigning our underground tube station
is or providing extra capacity there is
a is a tough one to do I may take many
years to do New York City is expanding
its bus only lanes to try and alleviate
overcrowding the idea is that if buses
have more space on the road they can
increase service which should make it
easier for riders to maintain social
distance on board there's every
possibility there's gonna be another
huge wave of infections just because we
are you know carrying the virus to
different to different places
dr. James hildreth has spent the last
four decades researching viruses if you
refuse to wear a mask as far as I'm
concerned you should not be allowed to
use the service because not doing so
puts others at risk shared surfaces and
limited air circulation pose a
particularly big risk for bus drivers
who are among the people who don't have
the choice to work from home after at
least 33 London bus workers died from
kovat 19 the mayor temporarily had
passengers enter the bus from the middle
doors to avoid contact with drivers
since then the city said it's worked
with researchers to improve the
protective screen between the driver and
pass
now some buses are running with limited
capacity and skipping stops when they
hit that limit I think it's inevitable
with a mass transit system that there
will be times when social distancing is
very difficult to manage what I tell my
team and my family is that we should all
expect to be doing this until the middle
of next year in the meantime some cities
are looking for ways to help people
avoid public transit altogether local
governments are now warning sidewalks on
taking space away from cars we have been
kind of reallocating Road space for
pedestrians incremental a pre-pandemic
but I think the the pandemic has given
it greater urgency the worry I've got is
that is because people aren't using
public transport they're returning to
cars so that's one of the reasons why
we're reallocating Road space for
pedestrians and cyclists if I unlimited
money I probably put more into Cycle
Hire really because I think that's
turned out to be really successful
London Milan Paris Bogota and Berlin
have all announced plans to expand
cycling lanes and governments are
encouraging people to walk to work if
they can some have talked about limiting
the need for people to use public
transit by building up local economies
with the fifteen-minute city it's an
urban planning concept that puts
people's basic needs like food parks and
schools all within a 15-minute walking
distance how will the city function
going forward is it going to flip to a
kind of more local London or is it going
to flip to more less people living in
London you know we don't know another
idea to take pressure off public transit
systems is to reevaluate the way we work
all together more companies are allowing
employees to work from home and some
transport authorities have suggested
that employers might be asked to stagger
shift times to avoid overloading trains
at rush hour so what is this all mean
for commuters so one of the things
thinking about is you know when this
pandemic is over how do we get people
back onto public transport in a way that
they feel safe public transit networks
don't operate under a global set of
rules so it's ultimately down to each
city and transit network to decide how
to move forward anybody will do is is
actually focus the minds of transit
authorities and local governments to say
more than ever we have to make sure that
the whole spectrum of users the poor
rich the women the people with
disabilities of different kinds have to
feel safe about that that's a big
challenge